le concept est différent en fait
amélioré sur le jazz parce qu'on se
recentre sur le jazz et c'est la
troisième année que que la formule
recentrage autour du jazz est mise en
place est fatale est vraiment ce sera un
paroxysme en plus c'est la clé 40 ans de
l'indépendance de sa plus si donc c'est
simplement une explosion de
deux choses de très qualitative
et le pays se prépare un paiement
recevoir
un très grand festival de jazz ça fait
maintenant quelques mois que
l'organisation est vraiment de
travailler en collaboration avec le jazz
at lincoln center qui est en fait là
la rolls pour des organisateurs et des
promoteurs de jazz à new york
et cette année ils ont choisi simple si
pour comme scène
pour leurs artistes internationaux il
sera vraiment vraiment de haute voltige
ce festival avec
des pointures comme diane diallo id brio
et potter
mario canonge aussi
enfin et il va réserver beaucoup de
surprises parce que les lieux sont
différent cette année alors que le
festival sera sur toute l'île du nord au
sud
vous aurez des lieux qui vont accueillir
le festival donc ce sera le festival
près de la plage de festivals dans le
jardin le festival dans un parc à la
marina est vraiment on a vite on a vite
on est ici pour inviter les martiniquais
à venir découvrir nouvelle formule c'est
à dire ce roi centrage autour du jazz
est faite cette diversité aussi de
e et de qualité pour la programmation on
reçoit ch depuis 20 ans tant que le
festival existe on a reçu des milliers
et des milliers des centaines des
milliers de martiniquais qui sont venus
des toits pendant toute une semaine
profitez du jazz donc oui ici c'est
vraiment vraiment ici ce soir pour dire
on martinique est venu
aussi vague de jazz parce que vous allez
retrouver votre formule de préférer là
pour me dit chasse d'autant plus que
plus tard dans l'année en août
on a aussi un festival roots and soul ou
là il ya de la musique r'n'b
et que sol de la musique reggae c'est
encore la fête la fête du festival de
jazz et la fête aussi de toutes les
autres musiques
on fait la renommée de sainte lucie en
tant qu'organisateur de festival
[Musique]